[Music]
can you tell us what you're doing on
this dancing with the stars tour how
many numbers you have are you doing all
the dates like what are the details well
I don't know exactly how many numbers
i'm doing but i am doing a couple of the
numbers that i did for the season so I'm
really excited which one are you most
excited about
I don't know all of them yeah skin it no
but um I think we're doing the ARA
Chicago like recreation so that's
probably one of my favorites the
Argentinian tango oh yeah and you're
going on tour with these guys I feel
like that's gonna be crazy are you ready
for that they're a rowdy bunch they're
hilarious i think they feel like we've
become a big family your past couple
weeks so this should be a lot of fun i
actually just had a first rehearsal
today so yeah I mean we were working on
opening numbers and stuff like that so
exciting it's nice to be able to go and
just to be yourself without having to
compete at the same time so you still
training in gymnastics when does that
I'll kick off for you again uh right now
I'm not and I think I'll definitely be
coming back just because you know this
word is still part of me but I'm
definitely gonna take a little break
just because this is a really break yeah
I hope some of the final five volts to
be coming and seeing you on tour look so
cool